[Musique]
on les trouve en
raccourci dans nos petites amours d'un
jour toutes les joies tous les soucis
des amours qui durent toujours c'est là
le sort de la
marine et de toutes nos petites chéries
on accoste vite un becin pour nos baiser
corps avec et les joies et les bouderies
les fâcheries les bons retour il y a
tout ça un
raccourci des grands amours dans nos
petits on a rit on s'est baisé sur les
nen les nénés
dans les cheveux à plein
d'éch pondu comme des œufs tout chauds
tout ce qu'on fait dans un seul jour et
comme on allonge le temps plus de trois
fois dans un seul jour content pas
content content il y a dans la chambre
une odeur d'amour tendre et de gû Ron ça
vous met
la joie au
cœur la peine aussi et c'est bon on
n'est pas là pour causer mais on pense
même dans l'amour on pense que demain il
fera jour et que c'est une calamité
c'est là le sort de la
marine et de toutes nos petites chéries
on accoste mais on devine
s'attrape pas le paradis on aura puse
des pêchés faire B Dieu la pigeotant et
le pourouré de tous nos péchés ça ne
sera pas ça et pourtant toutes les joies
tous les soucis des amours qui durent
toujours on les trouve en
raccourci dans au petit amour d'un
jour